you
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are going to be talking about the
global gift project and doing that with
us today is Jordan leisure on hey thanks
for having me on basic come on to the
show yeah really appreciate it
so we met what like two ish years ago
yeah and so we were working on some like
futurism world's for nano collab and
then we kept in touch to focus on like
some larger even scale ideas and
projects like how do we get the world to
work together mm-hmm and I've really
enjoyed that inspirational mentality
from you and now you're they're gonna
teach us about global gift project I'm
super excited to unpack that with you
and let's talk about let's talk a little
bit about your your what got you here
mm-hmm because I'd like maybe for the
authorities to get a quick a quick blurb
on the global gift project so why don't
you give that to us and then I'll ask
you more about how I got here cool so
the basic idea for the global gift
project was inspired by thinking about
the Statue of Liberty and how friends
gave that as a gift for the US and I
feel like that's something that we don't
really think about or really appreciate
like the magnitude of that being a gift
it's now you know it's like a statute
that's known around the world it's been
there for over a hundred years it's a
symbol of American culture and freedom
like worldwide and just what a cool
showing of goodwill between countries so
the idea is to kind of bring that back
and do it all over again in the 21st
century and to crowdfund a gigantic
piece of art about 80 feet tall to be
given as a gift from the people of the
u.s. to the people of Mexico what
they've been inspiring more
country-to-country gifts especially with
between countries that have been
traditionally at odds yeah
so what year was that that France gave
the u.s. it was like a 20 year process
it took a lot longer than they expected
it to because it was supposed to be a
gift for the
hundredth year anniversary of American
independence like 1876 and then it I
think it was like 90 1892 or something
when it was finally gifted 86 92
somewhere in there and that is has that
been the only large-scale gigantic piece
of art gifted from countries far as I
know especially a dot scale there's been
some smaller stuff recently but like
nothing like the Statue of Liberty where
like the whole world knows about it yeah
yeah yeah and I love the the thesis and
the inspiration behind this is the idea
of unity the idea of especially
countries that have had some sort of
conflict in the past to be able to say
like here this is the gift that we're
giving you so there's so much like
philosophy and so much unity and how
you're actually going about the
execution of this that we're gonna
unpack okay so now take us to Jordan
that was you know figuring out his life
and figuring out what he wanted to do
with his life so you ended up
co-founding futurism it's not like three
years or so ago and futurism is let's
you know we'll we can also pull up these
these assets along the way we're gonna
walk you guys through a couple of we're
gonna show some cool global gift project
work we're gonna show some cool futurism
work so I just wanna I just want to show
people this because I think this is
really important I don't know how many
people are aware of this publication do
you guys call it a publication is called
yeah publication so so futurism comm
covers so much interesting news like if
you go to this news tab advanced
transport AI block Nick which I don't
even know what block Nick oh that's just
our blockchain publication it's a
category 8 so yeah blockchain category
cool earth and energy enhanced humans
future Society hard science you know
robots and machines virtual virtuality
virtuality because it covers like
virtual reality augmented reality mixed
reality all that stuff yeah yeah and so
you you help to dis really kick off into
what it became and how did you I guess
how did you even land here and
also what did what like inspired you
guys to to make a publication about so
many important future concepts I'm
pretty much an obsession with with
technology and thinking about how AI and
robotics and you know self-driving cars
and nano and gene-editing
is going to drastically change our
society in the next 5 10 50 200 hundred
years and three years ago when this was
started these weren't like mainstream
topics really like most people didn't
realize that self-driving cars were
coming they didn't know about CRISPR
gene editing you know this this really
was not part of the cultural zeitgeist
people weren't aware of like all the
changes that were coming so the the
thesis was that people should know you
know they need to know how things are
gonna be changing especially so that
they can be informed so when things like
voting on these concepts come up then
they can vote with an informed mind
instead of just being fearful of robots
taking their job or like DNA gene
editing turning us all into like you
know half human half pig whatever
whatever people think when they think of
these these technologies that have long
been science fiction they're now very
rapidly becoming real yes the ideas to
educate more to popularize the
futuristic concepts that are really near
coming and like we got to know what
we're doing with these futuristic
concepts it's especially general public
getting more understanding about
especially things that are going to like
genetic engineering and artificial
intelligence to their max so okay so
cool and then you ended up so through
this process of co-founding of
publication maybe give the audience a
little insight into like what this was
like the whole process of figuring out
how to run a publication run a company
design and engineer the site make the
cool video content as well like yeah
tell us about that yeah sure so it's
come a long way in three years it was
three of us in an office above a bagel
shop in Brooklyn like three years ago
that's why I moved to New York to work
on futurism and originally it was a lot
different than it was now it was more so
like an aggregator for news from other
websites and then we quickly realized
how much more we could do by actually
creating the content ourselves yeah
amen why is there just wasn't enough
content to like this this stuff wasn't
really being covered yeah it was like
you know yeah we lived in a little
bubble here to where like CNN and Fox
homes don't cover AI as much as
TechCrunch and Mashable
totally yeah yeah right yeah and then we
got like an early break by publishing
this really popular infographic on
reddit called this week in science it
was like a you know kind of a square
infographic that had the top six stories
and science deck that week and it was
just a really easy digestible version
yes of all these stories people could
like go through and then start trickling
people from that back to futurism which
really built up the initial audience and
then we got really into doing short form
social videos like you know there's 30
second thirty to sixty second caption
videos you see everywhere now yes we
were like one of definitely one of the
first publications to do that in a
science and tech field and we were
pretty early overall anyways
so that's what helped really like launch
us off into having what I think's like 7
million or so Facebook fans yeah yeah
that's huge
yep I love how you did the whole three
people above a bagel shop and built it
up that's it's very inspirational you
got to find the waste to design
information that is novel and then get
it out to the masses like you did
through that infographic on reddit
through these 30-second videos that
became very popular and it's you know
it's these fast cuts it's a lot of the
time it's these really powerful stories
it's the way you overlay text onto the
video all these different strategies
which simulation needs to start doing
better we got we've got a long way to go
to get there but we're gonna get there
support us on patreon we'll get there
faster then prioritize in general what
we're up to
so okay so so okay so so so futurism is
growing you guys have you guys had a
team how ballers the team now I think
we're like 45 people ish yeah okay 45
people that's that's yeah that's really
big okay so over three years that that
grew very fast okay now what was this
moment for you
of like okay I built helpful futurism
that was amazing I loved it and I'm like
continue interacting with it engaging
with the team and stuff but I want to
focus more of my time on global gift
project how was that yeah how'd that
moment come to you
well global gift project was an idea
that had been kind of like inside me
like itching to come out for like like
the last three years
yeah even even before joining like
futurism in the early days that was like
the big question is like do I do this
thing it's like this really big idea and
it's like my heart project or you do
this thing that I'm like very excited by
and has a lot of potential momentum like
they're kind of like to two different
parts of me like technology and bringing
people together so after three years of
futurism and getting it to a level of
like success and you know a lot of
people actually knowing about these
technologies like I would say that the
topics we write about are like not even
like the future anymore you know like
Fox News is covering it now which is
crazy
yeah so I felt like a little bit mission
accomplished and now it's time to focus
on this thing that has been wanting to
come out for a long time and that I
think the world really needs yeah that's
a interesting way to put it you sort of
spark the fire under humanities asked to
talk about these subjects more and then
you're like okay and I can focus on this
massive passion project that I have that
I want to build okay so this is seven
months ago you know we were talking on
the phone about it and when I was first
hearing about it I was getting really
inspired about it you know how does this
idea even come to someone you know it's
funny I don't even remember how it was
it was like three years ago
and it's probably just me going on a
walk in the morning and thinking like
man like what what could I do I like
that would really get the world's
attention yes and call attention to the
fact that you know we think of ourselves
as what I think I like Colombian and
Algerian and American and Canadian first
yeah we have music that's orders let's
show that that so that's a really good
point so so I love the the the gift
that's orbiting earth is so freakin
awesome
okay so the goals of spark a chain
reaction of gifts between the countries
of the world okay and then here you
really break it down you know sounds
cool but why and this is really true
right here so continued name is Rita
here like our world is fragmented with
invisible borders we've made up these
borders that aren't really there and we
identify with those borders and see them
as like the other rights like us versus
them and we think of ourselves versus
German adriaen or Colombian rather than
simply human like row we're all really
the same meanwhile humanity is facing
monumental issues it will require global
cooperation to solve like the refugee
crisis the water crisis global warming
as a whole just I mean there's endless
problems that are what our news channels
are focusing on 24/7 we were talking
about AI in genetic engineering and all
these other things as well right for
that you guys talked about futurism got
current problems and impending problems
that are coming soon
and this project reminder seeks to
remind us that we're all just a bunch of
humans and we're in this together now no
it's so tough when civilization evolves
with borders it becomes so difficult to
imagine what it's like without borders
and it's like well we've been just what
borders since you know we were dirt so
it's just part of the evolutionary
process and it's something that we all
have to collectively agree on we got to
tear down these walls and borders and go
forward otherwise we'll just become
another lost civilization in which this
planet is littered with other things
borders are fine and they you're right
they're totally natural and it you could
kind of I just think we need to move up
one more level in terms of how we're
thinking about our fellow man so like if
you look at the United States right we
have like we have the states and those
are those are distinctly separate you
know they have their own governments and
their own laws but what's like what's
more important is that we're like we're
America
and like the country's sorry the country
as a whole
acts together and I don't think we
really have that as the globe as like
the human species so I'd like to push us
more towards okay first we are human oh
and then like below that unless unless
importance are these things we've
created called nations yeah what is so
important yeah yeah I think that's an
that's an interesting organizational
structure that might be the one that
makes sense for people that are also
very tied to their country and tied
because if you completely wash away then
they lose that sense of where they were
born and the culture in that area so so
it's okay so mmm so the ideas sure think
of yourself first this human first as
the collective and then secondarily also
think about your culture and where you
were born what part of the world that is
keep and then the way we interact or
change sports okay so now what does what
does looking at this massive list of
monumental problems and then thinking
okay if we exchange gigantic pieces of
art that might call them everyone down a
little and bring people closer together
is that about the yeah a little bit like
it's it's like I guess a little bit
abstract right art itself is abstract it
also makes it really powerful it's able
to kind of transcend politics and
borders and just like move past all the
[ __ ] and be like like we're giving
you a gift that's like something that's
universally understood as like oh like
wow like maybe we're we're maybe we're
not so different and the hope is to just
kind of just inspire people in general
to think about what's what's possible
and like to create like a good piece of
news it's like a really good piece of
news which we don't have very much of
that you know it's all like another war
started families of my separated at the
border like etc etc I can only imagine
what it will be like when we have a
tremendous amount of coverage around a
global gift that is delivered to
another country it's just so novel it's
so outside of the current narrative
which is that like things are [ __ ]
yeah right it's like Oh what well what
this is happening like if this could
happen what else could happen and then
of course the eventual the very ideal
outcome of this is that you have two
countries that like hate each other or
like actually at war and you have the
people from each of those countries
giving gifts to each other because is it
really like the people that look like
the people that hate the people of the
other country in some cases yes in some
cases yes really yeah you guys should
talk about this what do you disagree on
here I just think that kindred spirits
like each other and it's not the country
there aren't I don't think that really
exists that countries you know hate each
other I mean the ignorant among all of
the countries certainly may hate each
other countries that but I just think
are well educated people from all walks
of life in the land our open arms in
regards to respecting other cultures and
and people's that's just in my 51 years
hey what do I know
sure what do you think hmm unfortunately
the world is not comprised of that
minority or like I think you're much
people you're right the people that were
lucky enough to be born into a
circumstance allow them to be educated
and you know having trans-border you
know experience I parachute down I
didn't have the opportunity to turn into
me I'm my older brother turned into my
father and my younger brother turned
into my mother and my stepfather it's
just you know I didn't I don't know yeah
there there there is an interesting sort
of should we call it a tendency that
humans have to
to funnel into either ignorant or
knowledge a blue pillar red pill per se
and a lot of that does have to do with
our inherent nature and some of that has
to do with our nurture and I think
people can break through that along the
way I just personally think I'm
continuously ignorant for my whole life
because that's actually a very important
grounding point for myself to stay
humble but I think if you have people
talking across borders that think that
they know everything that's when you
have issues when people are trying to
combat over land over money over power
and they are like we were talking about
prior to this they haven't quite dosed
up on some psychedelics to be like yo
we're all one so this reminds me a lot
of like pushing people in the direction
of we're all one without the need for
psychedelics which is which is good
because a lot of people are scared of
psychedelics sure rightly so not me yeah
not me either that's true
Jordan not you either nope yeah you can
google me you'll quickly see that okay
so you know I kind of do want to want to
stay on this a little more about like
your inspiration about this and also
just overall philosophy abouts too bad
we can't showcase kind of what you're
thinking for this first one we will soon
we will soon be able to showcase what
gift looks like what you can teach us is
that it's coming from the United States
to Mexico and will hopefully be
delivered by 2020 definitely by 2020 yes
yeah yeah and we have an art piece that
is like in the final stages of being
developed and I can't release it
publicly just yet but it's gorgeous and
75 feet tall 75 feet tall and like we're
kind of like the the kind of feel we're
going forward like the statue of unity
statues like a follow up for the Statue
of Liberty unfortunately there's already
a statue called that and that will
actually be the biggest one in the world
in India but so if you think of a better
name let me know yeah
but yeah that's like the that's the
field we're going for and you know
there's this like I guess there's a
would you say the statue of unity
India's like this that guy that guy it's
a fat guy and like one of the men ever
United anybody like we're a divisive
like historically were very divisive
it's more as more so women really like
you know the feminine more so so I think
it makes more sense to have a woman
which is what what we're doing yeah so
okay so there's so you gave us a little
bit of woman can we talk about how there
is something a little bit more than just
a structure that there's lighting as
well can we mmm no wait we can wait okay
yeah so so that's an important aspect
you're not just the one trick it's not
just gonna be one piece of like metal or
steel or whatever there's more and it's
it's gorgeous so so that's that's good
okay
so gifted for sure by 2020 now let's
walk through kind of like how this works
because how the [ __ ] do you give a 75
foot statue to another country in the
world in two years like how do you
manage to pull that off yeah so we can
start with the crowdfunding campaign so
the interesting part is that will be
crowdfunding it with a limit of one
dollar per person that's a max and that
was like they're very much by design the
idea there is that it needs to be a gift
that comes from the people not from like
five billionaires not from like a bunch
of middle-class white people that have
like the you know the money to be able
to donate to something like this it
should be coming from people from all
walks of life all backgrounds and
circumstances like even you know like
the poorest among us have a dollar so
yeah it's so easy to venmo a dollar to
global gift project right there right
yeah easy thing you were teaching you
about this mentality of like even a
child has a dollar even shot is it a
dollar yeah at least I have it before
they spend it on candy yeah yeah yeah so
that's kind of part of it is like it's
such an easy ask you know it's like have
you given your doll yeah it's like so
simple yeah or this idea that's so big
and that's like a really big thing that
I'm trying to do with with this project
in particular is show that when a lot of
people come together and do one small
thing each that you can move mountains
that you can do huge
things they capture the world's
attention and can rewrite this this
story of mankind that we currently have
that's so powerful I love your vision
with that so okay so there is this whole
philosophy that you baked in about this
about $1 per person and I'm really
enjoying this so let's talk about a
little more a lot of what we see the
monumental change the mountains being
moved occurs a lot through the pans of
just a couple people and that's usually
this big money in politics or there's
big money in the private sector or
whatever making change through lobbyists
and through all this other kind of stuff
but when you when you can when you can
push a sort of a viral campaign and I
want to love for you to teach us about
how you're planning on doing this when
you can push multiple millions of people
across the world to give $1 each you can
show that there's so much power in these
small tiny movements of lots of people
and that's so interesting because I
don't think humans have figured out how
to unlock that potential yet so there's
a whole new game of potential that will
be unleashed when people realize that if
we all move them if we all push a little
bit of force we can all move the massive
mountain that's cool yeah I think
there's a story right now in general
that people don't care
they're like Millennials or you know
they don't they're not really doing
anything that like change the world I
think what's actually happening is that
a lot of people like most people have a
strong desire to do something good and
to make an impact but they just have no
idea where to start like the met the
problem seems so insurmountable but if
there was an opportunity in front of
them that required very little effort
and allow them to actually participate
in something that could do some good I
think they would jump at it $1 $1 yeah
like super simple and just to be clear
like this would be this is gonna cost
like three million dollars so I need
three million people just a small
percentage of the u.s. population what
it's like 1% it's like 1% yeah so it's
not it's not small but I also I love
that like if basically if I can't reach
3 million people with this I have failed
the idea
is not a good one and it's like the
world like not already you tourism like
yeah you can give I can't gets three
million people to give one dollar each
then I I give up
yeah yeah okay so so I never want to see
you give up ever oh I wouldn't really
good okay okay so okay so now teach us
about the campaign so you're gonna take
a 25-foot version yep yes smaller
version to give the you give the people
an idea of what it actually looks like
would say it's like it's gonna be three
times this size yeah and we're gonna do
a physical tour around the US and
something cool that most people don't
know is that the Statue of Liberty
itself was also crowdfunded so in France
they made the head and also the hand
holding the torch and they did the same
thing they toured it around friends and
they had people donate money to help
build the rest of it oh I'm serious
yeah like no it has a such a cool story
that's a true Liberty he did this whole
this the same thing it was like the
biggest crowdfunding campaign lv8 is so
interesting yeah
so yeah they toured it and people would
give money to like take photos with it
and climb on it and whatever else so
we're gonna replicate that and take this
25-foot version on a big flatbed truck
around the u.s. go to like you know
fairly major cities and the idea is that
people will be like waiting in line to
actually put their physical dollar into
like a physical container and like you
know take their Instagram photo like I
gave my dollar in front of this epic
piece of art yeah and that's just one
aspect of it and of course there's also
the online you know digital advertising
which I have a lot more experience in
but what's something I really love about
this is that I think if the physical is
important and I'm so digital for so long
and I'm like all about the future and
technology everything else like you know
someone texting a number to give a
dollar which will allow people to do is
cool it's cool but it's a different
thing than you coming out physically and
showing up and saying here's my [ __ ]
dollar and see the one-third sized
version of what you're supporting as
well right yeah which will be you know
the height of your ceiling which they
can't see but it's very tall yeah there
yeah there is a
a lofted ceiling in the space and the
structure I can't believe is gonna be
the height of this feeling that to the
one-third size structure okay
you know what else I thought is really
interesting Braun's currently showing
people on the robocam that like that so
this so what you see right now is gonna
be the 25-foot version it's gonna be
about that tall and that means three
times that height is going to be the
final version now you mentioned like
this so so interesting the Statue of
Liberty was was the head and the torch
was you know was brought around France
and oh that's so interesting so so are
you gonna enable people to also climb
the 25 foot version oh no no it's not
it'll be different yeah we thought about
doing like two pieces of it like they
originally did but I don't think it
would be quite as impressive as just
saying like the full version even a
smaller size you're right yuria and so
then nobody's climbing it you just have
to bother it
you might have like a little platform to
let people get higher up on it or
something yeah I have to take a photo
and yeah cuz otherwise you people we
might have to think about how to master
the best way for people to be able to
take a photo I know right otherwise it's
gonna be like really low it'll be low
exactly so that's kind of cool that you
can't even see it like so tall that
either just like whoa what's that thing
you're setting in front of yeah
otherwise you look like an ant when they
go really far back right yeah yeah yeah
what no I'm good yeah okay so an
interesting thought as well about the
about the like taking this on a truck
bed mmm you can be moving this from New
York to East Coast cities and then to
some Midwest surround yeah yeah those
are around is crazy you're putting this
on a truck bed so okay so now the 25
foot version timeline-wise what is our
timeline for that and then when does it
go on tour
so the timeline is finalizing the piece
of art which is well underway so
probably a few more months definitely a
few more months until the the 25-foot
version is done and then once I have
2019 tour starts ish first yeah yeah I
would say early at 19 yeah
and then once I have the art finalized
I'll be reaching out to figures in
Mexico like mayors who would have the
ability to say yes we'll receive this
gift yes just need a place to put it or
a minute play yeah that's central where
can get a lot of attention exactly we
want to help with that we're gonna help
with marketing the crap out of getting
all these different cities in the u.s.
to donate to it are you allowing people
around the world no this is just the
u.s. because if they get interesting too
I mean if someone want to like pretend
to be you know like I'm not gonna do
like you know your customers like you
blocking like I can do that but we're
only gonna be marketing within the US
yes and saying hey this is from the
people in the US gotcha gotcha yeah so
but then at the end you could seal
you'll it'd be interesting to know if
you got 85% of the funds from the US or
or whatever yeah we can also set those
funds aside that come from international
people that's it you guys the the extra
money from the campaign assuming we go
above and beyond 3 million which is the
goal would be seed funding for
additional gifts like we're hoping that
people see this around the world and
like that's awesome I want to do that
like I I'm an artist as I like I want to
create a gift that's not even art
something else something different and
they will send us proposals and we you
know send maybe you know three groups
around the world some money to get
started on their own version of their
global gift I'm I'm in I'm in love with
the idea of the earth becoming littered
with gifts from countries I'm just
envisioning I'm envisioning this right
here I'm envisioning this and and every
single time one of these packages lands
this new beautiful like 40 foot or 80
foot or 200 foot wide maybe gift emerges
in this different country gifted by
another country and then it just becomes
this it could become these new wonders
of
earth as well which I love the idea of
that that we've been we've been so lost
from that sort of ideology focused on so
much other stuff with the Industrial
Revolution this explosion of of
Technology and work that we forgot about
this is the blessing of being able to
deliver the gigantic pieces of art to
each other yeah forget anything
we're just programmed to be hateful and
war mongers and create criminals to
populate our private prisons nobody
forgot anything we're trying to deal
with simulation go ahead there's a lot
of distractions rounds rounds right and
it makes it difficult to pursue projects
like this but clear thinking will get us
to an inspiration for the next ones I
like how you think
past the we're gonna get past their goal
we're going to put that money into a
seed for another project from another
country to another country wherever they
want to do it yeah I mean the way I see
it is that either people get this idea
and they like love it so I think it's
like a very like binary outcome it's
like either I'm totally off and all the
people that I've been talking to that
love this idea or like are also wrong
and the world will not get this or it's
gonna be like wow this is really cool
and it's gonna skyrocket we'll see
this might be one of the first sort of
ideas that I think more than 50 percent
of humanity might be in favor for I
think I don't know how you could be
against it yeah yeah like maybe neutral
possibly maybe neutral why would you
ever be against a be like that's stupid
use of money I guess somebody could say
I shouldn't have done the stupid person
voice but that I wanna I would like to
hear yeah that was a good stupid person
[Music]
always are the waste of money yeah white
like I would love to hear your
counter-argument if you have one comment
below with why this is a waste of money
why it's this bad idea because it's
important to hear other people's
perspectives on no it isn't keep just
keep doing what you're doing
don't mind the haters so so okay so now
in 2019 this is starting to be trucked
around are you gonna start with your in
start with East Coast cities not it's
probably gonna be starting on the west
coast that's what it is assembled on the
east west coast it is assembled on the
West yeah okay I thought the artists
that you were working was gonna be no
that's actually why I'm here in SF
because I mean collab with artists huh
interesting
okay then this artist has done some work
with like Burning Man another sort maybe
maybe maybe okay okay good good okay
we'll keep it maybe for now this artist
has enough credentials to to certainly
yeah okay it gets okay so it gets made
here and then it starts in San Francisco
in the Bay Area and then it goes down to
like LA Seattle San Diego and then it
moves Las Vegas and Phoenix and blah
blah and this moves across them yeah
it'll be a multi month campaign
full-time month campaign so you're 2019
fundraising and then you'll be every
dollar structure yep that's how it's the
fun yeah so and we'll be accepting
dollars in a multitude of ways basically
making it as easy as possible for anyone
to send in a dollar so we'll have like a
mailing address where you can mail
physical dollars number you can text to
send a dollar and a cost
50 Cent's to send a dollar yeah yeah I
know all right and we're trying to avoid
you know online transactions where
there's like a credit card for you like
don't even have to this side and a half
percent in ten cents because that's like
twelve twelve percent of what they'd be
giving or currency would cost more than
the dollar the gas price yeah that's
crazy sense yeah yeah we're not good at
micro transactions yet yeah yeah yeah
just said no matter who you are you're
like the grandma that like you know
still mails $20 checks or like cash to
your net for my grandchildren or the
birthday is like great we gotcha Covered
where we get a t-shirt those futurism
t-shirts I want to get one for my niece
and nephew unfortunately they're not
publicly available yeah well you know
that'd be good way to raise some money
yeah same you know you know there's a
couple things
um first of all we'll have to get maybe
get a future some t-shirts somehow we'll
pry it oh I think we can make that maybe
we can make that happen on you know what
else we need is we need you it would be
great if Global gift project also had a
little tiny like shirt like hey you love
this design like it would be great to
have a little earth with a little gift
on it yeah
like that would be a cool shirt yeah I
think a lot of people would like that
shirt so yeah I'd be super down for that
okay so all these different ways to see
the microtransactions now you're getting
them in as you're as you're traveling
something that I that I really thought
was was a good point as well was okay
you mentioned this I'm coming to the
bottom of this 25-foot strategy I'm
really enamored by it I love it and then
I you know I don't donate the dollar
I take Instagram photos so now this is
part of the marketing genius yeah it's
like have you given your dollar like be
a part of history know how hard it is
yeah kind of like ice bucket challenge
right where it just it was like the
thing to do it was like the cool thing
to do
yeah to go and like pour this ice bucket
over your head and I'm asking me to do
something far less extreme than that
it's like come out and put a dollar in a
box that's like really iconic so when
you see this photo on Instagram exactly
don't see a thousand of them you know
it'll be like your whole feed yep
exactly Global gift project will be a
hashtag you'll be a you know it's its
own Instagram yeah and so then you can
surf through the tags you can
you're getting this is genius in terms
of marketing as well just because of the
sheer amount of impressions and you're
doing a little bit of the of the Jones
effect you know Oh Jordan has donated
his dollar have you know have has Alan
donated as dollar yeah and and then the
others this whole being a part of
history that's great yeah yeah something
else we're doing what you think kind of
goes along with the theme of asking very
little of people is instead of asking
people to like share with like three or
five people or 10 people or their whole
email list or their whole social media
following just one person just like pick
one person that you know and it'd be
like hey and write out a message to them
and say hey like this is really cool
would you please just take 10 seconds to
give a dollar in any of these 17 ways
yeah yeah it's like making it makes it
simple thank you Ron
no that wasn't it was this fart sound
but you can do that anywhere at a 37
perfect yeah good call so I'm just like
I'm really happy that you have a vision
like this I'm happy that these young
people that do things like this yeah
it's just interested in gaming
yeah yeah there's also a certain amount
of you know Jordan uses with you know
you use with global gift project right
now and like and you lose with the with
the execution expertise the marketing
expertise and like that's really
interactive you know I seem uniquely
suited to do it I've been for
crowdfunding campaigns each all
successful each gotten better than the
previous one I've built you know two
major online publications and done like
the marketing thing and then I think
this idea just kind of markets itself
it's so unique it so out do you
attribute your upbringing kid who you
are today I've certainly played a role
very similar to my father I'd say how so
- yeah at most ways he's not a nerd okay
you know he's got some pretty wild out
there ideas he always encouraged me like
when I dropped out of college he was the
one that was like yeah who'll do it
no no no dad drug that dad I ever told
that yeah that's good we got a cool dad
yeah I'm not formally trained on my
craft you know I mean I wouldn't have
mind on college but it didn't hurt me
not going
ron's definitely a cool uncle he's got a
niece and nephew that like he he smoke
pot with but they love it a little like
it's wrong so fresh for them because
he's so much different than normal
humans are when they engage with them so
you know he's fresh in that sense I'm
like you know your dad seems to be like
fresh and his ability to be like all
right go do it's okay so entrepreneur so
you see some of yourself in in him in
that sense yeah but other than that like
not really
it's like raised super Christian to
always ten like you were yeah actually
my dad was a pastor until I was 10 and
then he's come a long way since then I'm
down with the king
all right don't be you know it's not a
bad base it's I don't regret my you know
you know Catholic upbringing for sure
yeah but I you know you just kind of
evolved into you got to be careful every
religion out there has been hijacked by
its adversary so you know you have to
you have to be cautious but I'm down
with the king
Jordan I wanna I'm gonna address you
know a couple maybe more like bigger
vision points about this I mean you've
already went through a lot of the nuance
which is great is there a important
place to go after the u.s. giving a gift
to Mexico that you would say is like
another crucial place on the planet to
do this I mean there's a number of
countries that have far more conflict
between them than us and Mexico I talk
about Russia and Ukraine Israel and
Palestine India and Pakistan yeah you
know there's no number there's no
shortage of conflicts abroad
yeah yeah divide and conquer
and in is is there one that of those
that really rings a or D or do you just
be just hope that it ends up being that
other yeah I just hope it ends up being
that I hope other people will see this
and love us and want to want to
duplicate it then you can use the
template that I've created to do the
same thing are you gonna potentially
open-source the template itself that oh
yeah whatever can be open source will be
open source
the websites up on github if we will we
might use IndieGoGo or Kickstarter Evan
approached them yet about the $1 limit
they would have to change the way their
platforms work in order to use that so
either they'll be down or we can just
use an open source code base for
crowdfunding on our own domain either
way yeah yeah yeah yeah because it would
be important for whoever wants to do sex
I I think you're I think you're gonna
end up needing to be a little bit more
involved in like you said you're gonna
put some money in for the seed next seed
for the next one um I think you're gonna
end up needing to be a little bit more
involved as it gets going cuz I I would
love to just envision a place where four
countries decide in 2020 right after
this that they want to do it mm-hmm I
would love to I think we'd act as more
like consultants yeah I don't know I
could pretend how to do marketing in
like Spain yeah you know I'm sure it's a
hell of a lot different than the US
which is what I know so yeah I like will
help out with whatever they ask for help
with yeah any other like pressing
thoughts around the globe will give
project that you think are important to
share hmm well I'll say if you if you
love this idea out there and you want to
be involved this is like early days and
if you want to join the team and and
contribute there's a number of ways that
everyone could help out so feel free to
email actually if you go to global give
project.org there is a well actually
I'll push it tonight there'll be a forum
at the bottom where you can apply to
actually be a part of the team to work
on this that's great
be it you know
part-time full-time one-hour week
whatever yeah yeah that's great to have
all of those available options for
people to get involved in whatever
amount they think that they can for
example mm-hmm I think a way that many
people can be involved it's just the
start simply telling other people about
it I've I'm a big proponent of this at
the end of the show and I like that I'll
make federally we are here to you have
some insights into a couple things that
I think we should address towards the
end of the show here maybe the first one
being mythology I think you have an
interesting take on some things
regarding maybe like actualizations of
oneself or pursuing one's bliss teach us
about this I've been a major proponent
of people taking radical action to
follow what they feel really passionate
about in the world I think that the
people that are really doing big things
the people that are revered you know
like the celebrities didn't cool stuff
like that so that's all they're doing
they have a radical idea and they jumped
off the cliff completely and and devoted
their life to it so if if you're able to
do that like people are going to know
you you're gonna make an impact in the
world you're gonna have success you have
everything you know that people would
normal people in society want but in in
terms of like mythology overall an
interesting conversation this week
talking to actually the artist for
global gift project and we were talking
about how there's not really a mythology
like a story that humanity has for how
we'll get out of the problems that we've
created for ourselves like the the the
reigning narrative right now is that
like things are [ __ ] you know and
we're probably not gonna get out like
how are we gonna solve all these
problems we were so far away from world
peace there's still mass you know hunger
and like climate change being probably
like the scariest thing where all these
statistics are coming out like the
narrative is that things are bad things
are really rebelled it really bad and I
think that we need a new narrative to
like to like stand on top of that gives
us a way forward and so that's kind of
like what I've realized I'm trying to do
with this and what kind of like the
overall theme of this which is telling
people that we as individuals are
extremely powerful if we're able to come
together and we don't need to do that
much you need to quit your job and like
you know just stop eating for a year and
protest and you know you don't need to
do something extreme if you're not in
that position to do that so I want to
create opportunities for everybody no
matter their background and
circumstances to take small action in a
huge group and reestablish this
narrative that we're in control we have
power as individuals and we can actually
make the changes we need to get out of
the situation that we're currently in
yeah there's two things there that
thought were really important I'm the
first one being that the sort of radical
change that happens when one follows
their passion that if they take a
radicals change in that direction that
that's usually where the most meaningful
fulfillment actualization comes from in
life I love that and we try our best of
you know go go do that take that massive
Ritz go do that because it's it's
usually where you find the most meaning
and then the other thing that you said
that was really crucial there I think
was there's really no narrative for
something like what you're building the
global gift project there's no narrative
for kind of getting humanity to be more
there there are there is so much
mythology I can't even talk about it cuz
I know nothing about it but but just
classic mythology follow us a lot of it
like heroes or heroines to a journey
it's etc and that's kind of what we're
talking about with unleashing your own
full potential and everything but at the
same time this is more this is a lot of
this is you know taking civilization on
your back and like a novel and unique
way all right how about how about a
couple other points you have you have
you have a stances on virtual reality
and universe basic income teaches about
what you think about those two UVI is
probably the thing I'm most
passionate about that's like a really
hard like concrete solution to a lot of
the problems that we're facing I see it
as a like a root-level solution that if
implemented would like trickle up and
and enable us to solve many of the other
problems that we're facing like so if
for those not familiar universal basic
income or ubi
is the concept of generally the
government giving an unconditional
payment to every single citizen every
month like the the value use most often
is a thousand dollars a month and the
important bar here is unconditional we
were bonding over Andrew yang right yeah
right yeah Andrew yang one 1k a month
unconditional from the government funded
you know two trillion dollars has to be
funded somehow and there's a whole you
know he talks about it on our episode
but it needs to be funded and like you
said it can trickle up but you bi can
yeah so I think the powerful part of it
is that it provides this safety net that
enables people to take risks that would
allow them to do work that would be
really impactful for the world so for
example potential entrepreneurs people
that have an idea but are like working a
really shitty job or like or even you
know maybe supporting other people too
that don't have it they don't have the
option of quitting and focusing on that
thing this at least provides some means
for someone to be like actually you know
I'm I'm gonna quit this job and I'm
gonna give it like six months
you know I I'm not gonna go to live well
I'm gonna eat ramen but I'll be able to
pay my rent and like not be on the
streets and it'll give me you know as
much time as I need to work in this idea
it's just like it's amazing safety net
it's kind of crazy that we don't have it
and we have you know social security and
welfare and like these systems but these
systems are very very broken like the
main part with with welfare is that
there is this strange like gap basically
where it often makes more sense to stay
in welfare than it does to get a job
because you have someone welfare they
get paid a certain amount of money and
if they get a job now they're working
you know eight-hour days six days a week
and they're getting they're getting paid
barely more or the same or even
potentially less than they would with
just taking well
which is crazy so it's disincentivizing
people from going out and creating value
because if they do then they get their
safety net taken away yeah whereas ubi
it's and conditional no matter what you
do it's there and also I think there's a
ton of jobs that are not even jobs or
like things that people could be doing
that we don't really ascribe value to
because they don't generate income
totally like a volunteering yeah
volunteering community building events
like things that we really need a lot of
right now like especially with how like
[ __ ] up things are now unhappy people
are and like mental illness being a huge
issue a lot of these jobs that are super
necessary they they don't generate
income so this would allow or further
allow people to to do those types
interesting that the market doesn't
value them but the community values them
and right yeah yeah yeah they're not
getting paid in that sense and but
they're desperately needed and this
would enable more people to potentially
do community work and so many of these
desperately needed and it unlocks the
creative potential and so many people
right yeah yeah and like what what would
happen if this enabled just twice as
many people like say an extra percent of
our humans to be able to be doing what
they're meant to be doing like the thing
that they were born to do that they had
this any unique skill set or experience
that nobody else has and right like how
many Einsteins were missing out on
because you know they're stuck in the
mailroom
what if Einstein had stayed and in the
Patent Office instead of doing what he
did yeah you know if we just unlocked
another percentage point point of the
people that were doing that that's huge
that's massive yeah let alone like two
percentage points three five yeah yeah
so I think the the effects of UV are
really hard to quantify and that's
something that's really important to
point out when people are talking about
the cost of UV I it's like well what
about the what about the the the the
cost we can't quantify that we're losing
right now yeah because people are [ __ ]
they have no option yeah so it's a
really interesting experiment that will
likely be run 2020 in the United States
well I mean look at all there's been
tons of experiments I haven't found a
single one that hasn't turned up really
really positive results I mean one
common thing that people say is I go if
you give like poor people money they're
going to spend
alcohol and gambling and drugs and sex
turns out that's not true at all
like no experiment in any of the
experiments has shown that if you give
people enough money to actually make a
difference in their lives they will
spend that money properly and they'll
spend it well if you give a homeless guy
20 20 bucks that's not enough for him to
get an apartment or a job or like you
know be able to shower and buy a suit
and get it like that's not enough
so yeah I'm spinning I'm beer for sure
because this isn't gonna dig me out of
the hole give that same person $1,000 a
month the perspective is completely
different there's still exceptions to
this rules I still think we're gonna
have issues with some people doing
exactly what you say they're not going
to do that like that's that's right yeah
I just don't I don't think so you say
like everyone will do that is fair at
all
totally well then we just kill him oh
gosh if only we were in better control
of working together I think we're
getting there we're getting there
I think ubi has a lot of potential as
well okay how about a couple quick
couple quick thoughts on the way out
this has been very enriching global gift
project we like to ask a couple
questions at the end of the show we'll
keep them speed around on them but all
right do you think we're alone in the
cosmos I mean it's like mathematically
impossible so no I don't I don't have an
answer for why we haven't heard from
them yet but you know google it there's
a billion propositions for why that is
an answer to the Fermi paradox and yeah
so I know I don't think really do you
think we're in a simulation yeah I do
yeah dang is that I can explain that one
too please and it actually kind of goes
into virtual reality a little bit
perfect yeah let's see so you know we've
been around for however long as a civil
as like as humans and we've come to the
point where we have pretty realistic
virtual reality I don't envy if you have
tried anything it's pretty [ __ ] good
and it's only you know really the first
six six years of it ish seven years so
give us another 50 years
we're gonna have some something that is
indistinguishable from reality and you
know you're going to be living and
they're like interacting in these worlds
that are just potentially even like
better like you might just want to live
in a virtual world all the time because
it's better than what we have here
infinite possibilities you can design it
whatever and I think that something that
would naturally happen if possible is
let's say you're in this game and it's
already really realistic
the one thing they could make it more
realistic is if you forget that you're
in the game right like if you gave me
that option like you know you're gonna
be in this video game for a half-hour
and you're gonna completely forget that
it's not real and that's gonna make it
so much more thrilling for you I'd be
like yeah I'll try that for sure I would
try that so that's pretty much a
simulated reality right and I just think
that the chances of that of this being
the first time ever in the you know the
entire history of reality that this is
happening pretty [ __ ] slim so yeah
yeah I like how Jordan explains it from
the perspective of of being like okay
now you're you know you're 50 years
forward with the whole vert and
distinguishable virtual reality thing
you're drunk you're jumping into
whatever virtual worlds you want you're
just basically swimming through
differently designed worlds at your
leisure and then you're just like this
is so much better I just completely
forgot that I was even in a virtual
world that's right and then you're in
the then you've designed a world where
you're also then designing simulated
worlds because you want to explore and
understand where those worlds look like
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's interesting
[ __ ] yeah yes sir thanks for being at
the forefront of what I think is also
happening and those from those who've
watched Rick and Morty would understand
this but it's also not too crazy for me
to offer you the opportunity to live an
entire life within VR that only takes a
second in like in this like real reality
yeah you know if I was like you could
live live you know in 90 years as Alan
and you run this like this show called
simulation and you do that you're like
yeah I like this fear is that it's only
gonna be 10 seconds of my real
sure why not sounds pretty cool again
like the chances of that list being the
first time that that's possible pretty
unlikely okay just like aliens that
exist unlikely oh you want to spend
another 10 seconds evolving on a rock
that orbits two stars instead of one
yeah I want to see what that's like you
get a hundred forty years there they
have their they have a little longer
that it's like oh yeah yeah this time
all this time you run oh I love it oh
man we should let's let's stay just a
couple quick more minutes on simulation
theory exactly I feel like you know
you've unpacked it and good enough
detail sometimes the guests on the show
when we are expanding their dimensions
to these new areas of thought sometimes
the answers can be kind of binary or it
can be like not very you know thought
out super well but you know yours is
thought out quite well and we also tend
to be very aware of the vastness of the
cosmic perspective as well as the length
and so it in a quick question what then
would reality be if there are so many
embeds that are going on then that's a
great question I mean I think we're
likely many many many levels deep you
know it's like what's more crazy than
experiencing this world like oh you're
in this world experiencing like this
other simulated world you're like many
many many levels from remembering what
is truly going on yeah yeah okay so
interesting many levels away from
knowing what's truly going on how about
how about what would the infrastructure
look like for your this is let's say
this is jordyn legends avatar this year
your avatar in this life is time okay
time okay time just a lot last thought
about simulation three let's say this is
your avatars like we had mojo dot on the
show and we were talking - Mogo doubt
about things and he firmly believes that
this is just your avatar and that you're
you're somewhere else
mmhmm yeah so what would that somewhere
else look like and would that you know
you know maybe it's just like maybe
we're pure energy or some type IP no
idea yeah yeah I think that's kind of a
the state of things is that we have this
is all we have to like measure you know
and I think it's very likely that we
created something completely different
to experience because why why create the
same thing yeah yeah like we've already
done that yeah yeah so just one last one
last thought about submission theory
there's there's just something about
looking at the hundred plus billion
people that have lived and died before
us today that have built this world that
we live in and when I like today for
some [ __ ] reason I had the visual
like a visceral emotional experience of
being a woman that was stitching
together a United States flag in like
1780 or a nine years after us yessum
Betsy Ross life I'm serious it was
[ __ ] weird so my energy was you know
what I mean like why am i living in
someone else's life from the past what
is going out to collect a field of
consciousness and rebirths and all oh
[ __ ] oh yeah very last question what he
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world
hmm that's a great question I don't
think I've ever been asked that take it
mmm
yeah I think it's I think it mean to go
along with all we've been saying I think
it's people coming together especially
when they have to go through go through
some [ __ ] you know like they're they're
at odds and they still come together for
me the entire inspiration for all these
ideas was going to Coachella in 2004 and
seeing my favorite band at the time
Coldplay and they did the thing where
they stopped singing and they put the
audience or the the microphone out and
the entire audience you know like I
don't know ten thousand people he's all
singing in unison and I remember getting
like crazy chills yes of just like even
now it is every time I talk about it
getting chills
yes so I think that's beautiful and
we've talked about that similar concept
of imagine if everybody on the planet
was just like hey at 12 from noon until
12:15 p.m. nobody can use the economy or
use political systems or use technology
everyone's just gotta slow down and
meditate and then potentially unlock
some sort of collective field of energy
magic we all thought about the same
thing at the same time Jordan what a
freaking pleasure it is like most of you
thank you for coming on to our show
thank you so much love for the global
gift project and you know links in the
bio go check out global gift project
hopefully this has inspired you to think
about our world differently how we can
collaborate together how we can do
things like gigantic pieces of art let's
rebirth that just like we're rebirthing
and publicly like intellectual let's
rebirth doing cool gift projects across
the planet go check out the links in the
bio definitely go and share this to
other people go and start talking them
about it go and make content with this
don't just consume go create create
videos create blog post go make stuff
subscribe comment below with your
thoughts let's start talking about all
this cool stuff as a community join us
on patreon to help us scale the our
impact more people inspire more people
in this way thank you Ron our producer
director thanks Jordan much love
everyone
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]